Barack Obama might be a little bit light
in the loafers this is breaking news and
it's not from some tabloid and it's not
from some Far Right Kook it's from David
Garrow who is a very very serious
biographer and he has discovered that
Obama wrote letters to a girlfriend when
he was at Occidental College which is
the college he went to before he
transferred to Columbia
and he apparently expressed his desire
to do all sorts of strange things with
men according to Garrow with Alex McNair
who is Obama's girlfriend I think she
wanted to have her role known so when
Alex showed me the letters from Barack
she redacted one paragraph in one of
them and just said it's about
homosexuality I have a hot take on this
Revelation from Obama's biographer that
he had homosexual fantasies and wrote
about them to his girlfriend
Ah that's my hot take my heart exam the
main conservative hot take I'm seeing is
he's uh FANUC you know he's lighting the
loafers and I think I don't know maybe